what what's the uh kind of culture or
relationship those seven
guys have as they're competing is this
like a friendly thing or is this like
at all costs i'm making this team and i
know that if i make it that means
there's one less spot for these other
six guys
uh it's a it's definitely a weird
dynamic um
but i would say it's it's friendly that
there's a sense of
camaraderie there that you know you know
you're all in the same boat and
uh basketball is a sport where there's a
lot of player movement and you're going
to see
people you know down the road whether
it's
play with them that season or it could
be five years down the line so
it's definitely competitive but there's
a sense of camaraderie there because
it's a highly
stressful situation and nobody really
understands it
apart from the seven people in that room
yeah
um and then obviously uh you go on and
you play with
some of the biggest stars today right
with uh i think lebron was on that team
kyrie uh jr smith i mean there was a
whole roster full
uh what is it like kind of going
undrafted
then signing you know pretty big
contract and getting to play
with those people and then ultimately
play for the nba championship
yeah yeah no it's um
amazing kind of feeling to go from that
to
to then winning a championship um kevin
love was another one on that team and
um so the first year was the year before
lebron had come back to cleveland
um so we actually missed the playoffs
that year and then
at that summer league was when um you
know he announced he was coming back and
and everything changed like what our
guys on the team said
it's just like such a like a crazy
dynamic right it's like he left there
was this vacuum
and then when he announces he's coming
back i think fans see uh
like outside looking in but are you
players like all texting each other
being like wait is he serious or like
like what is the kind of conversation
yeah i think
uh we're in vegas for some league when
the announcement happened i think it was
on espn
and then we had a shoot around or a game
day
uh that day and uh i think
the the gm came over and whispered
something to
uh the coach at the time david blatt and
you could see his face kind of light up
in a big smile
and um then they announced it and
everyone's like wow this is
pretty crazy but then i think the next
thought at least for me was
i hope i'm still on on this team because
a lot can happen from
summer league to the time the season
starts and
at that point i was on a still on a
basically a year by year deal so
even after i made the team uh in that
september
october time period they could have cut
me any time before
january 15 before my contract was
guaranteed for the rest of the season
and then they had an option for me
the next season as well so you never
really
uh have a secure place yeah
um and then last thing i wanna ask about
basketball is uh you play with j.r smith
and uh my friends and i like he's one of
our favorite players mainly just because
he
you never know what he's gonna do he
might come down the court and i think
there's a
famous uh lebron interview where he's
literally like that guy i'll shoot from
anywhere he just crosses half court
he'll chuck it up
uh but he seems like like super cool
nice guy or whatever was it like playing
with him
it's funny because after you know the
lebron and janus questions he's probably
the teammate i get
asked the most about and he's awesome
i mean i love jr he he always had your
back as a teammate
um he had the neat name when the shot
clock's running down you can
you know give him the ball with two or
three seconds left and
those are the type of shots he he makes
he's a shot maker and
i'm happy he's got another opportunity
now with the lakers
yeah it's pretty cool